in this video we're going to cover what
criteria
a non-citizen must meet to become a
citizen
a process we call naturalization some of
the requirements are obvious and
verifiable
while others are tested through the
naturalization process
there are nine requirements that an
immigrant must
meet before they can apply for
naturalization and
four of the first five all have to do
with how
long an applicant has lived in the
united states
first they have to be 18 years old does
this mean that
children can't become citizens no but
they can't apply on their own
if their parent or parents apply for
naturalization a child can
inherit their parents citizenship if
they make it through the process
second the applicant has to have been a
permanent resident for at least
five years unless they're married to an
american citizen
then it's only three years so this means
that undocumented immigrants
and foreign diplomats are not eligible
for naturalization
third they have to show that they've
lived in the u.s customs and immigration
services district they've been living in
when they applied for at least
three months there are 26 uscis
districts which also include u.s
territories
fourth they have to have lived in the
united states continuously
for at least five years a green card
holder can leave for short periods of
time
but if they've lived outside the united
states for more than six months
they could compromise their eligibility
for naturalization
included in that is the fifth
requirement that they have to have been
physically present in the united states
for at least
30 months out of the five years of
residency they maintained
before they filed their application for
naturalization
these five cover the residency
requirements for naturalization but
there are four
other requirements that are verified
during the naturalization process itself
if you remember the steps of the
naturalization process
you should remember that at one point a
person seeking naturalization
needs to meet with a uscis official
for an interview and to take the
naturalization test
it's during this step that the uscis
official
tests the applicant on the next two
requirements
their ability to understand english and
their knowledge of u.s history and
government
the federal government requires that all
naturalized citizens can
read write speak and understand
conversational english the interview
itself serves as the test for the
speaking portion
and after the interview the applicant
has to read
one out of three chosen sentences
correctly
and for the writing test the applicant
will write an
english sentence provided by the
interviewer
following the english portion the
interviewer asks 10
questions about u.s history and
government and the applicant must answer
at least
six correctly some examples of questions
that an interviewer can ask are
how many amendments does the
constitution have or
who's in charge of the executive branch
then
there are only two requirements left and
they're the hardest
to verify because they aren't entirely
obvious
the eighth requirement for
naturalization is that you have to be a
person of
good moral character trying to determine
a person's character is hard to do
do you think you could get a good grasp
of a person's character
in an interview that lasts a few hours
or reading an application they filled
out
the way the government determines moral
character is by looking to see if an
applicant has a criminal history
but that isn't exactly foolproof they
can look into
american criminal databases but they
don't have access to other countries
criminal records
uscis often has to rely on
self-reporting
and while it is rare for someone with a
criminal history to make it through the
naturalization process
it has been known to happen the final
requirement is that the applicant has to
demonstrate an attachment
to the principles and ideals of the us
constitution
this means that an applicant has to
prove that they would actively support
the constitution
and support a democratic form of
government if someone is hostile to the
form of government in the united states
they cannot become a citizen one way
that a person proves this
is by agreeing to take an oath of
allegiance in a public ceremony
in this oath they must promise to
renounce
all foreign allegiance though that does
not mean they have to give up their
citizenship to other countries
and promise to give full allegiance to
the united states
its constitution and its laws they must
also promise to perform all duties and
obligations of citizenship
including defending the country when
called upon
so now that we've covered all of the
requirements let's go through an example
to see if you can determine whether an
immigrant is eligible for citizenship or
not
lorenzo has lived most of his life in
italy
but now he wants to become a us citizen
he came to the united states three years
ago and has been a legal resident
ever since he has never been in trouble
with the law
either in the united states or in italy
he enjoys owning his own home and living
in a friendly neighborhood
lorenzo is 25 years old speaks english
very well
and has recently taken a class at a
local community college on u.s history
for new citizens
he filled out his naturalization
application form
last week so let's check off all the
requirements that lorenzo does have
take a second and pause this video to
try and figure it out on your own first
all right so lorenzo is 25 years old so
he meets the minimum age requirement
he's only been a permanent resident for
three years
and he's not married to a u.s citizen so
he doesn't meet the residency
requirement
he's lived in portland for three years
so he meets the third and fifth
requirements
but he doesn't meet the fourth
requirement
lorenzo can speak english very well and
took a class on u.s history for new
immigrants
so we can assume that he can pass both
portions of the naturalization test
and since he's never been in any legal
trouble we'll put a check mark next to
him having good moral character
we can't exactly tell if he's attached
to the principles and ideals of the us
constitution
so we'll put a question mark next to
that requirement
all right given all this information do
you think lorenzo
is eligible to apply for naturalization
if you answered no you're correct even
though lorenzo meets
a lot of the requirements he doesn't
meet all of them
and eligibility is an all or nothing
type deal he has to meet
all nine requirements before he can
apply in the next video we'll cover some
of the
challenges of the naturalization process